and i love ben and everything is going
well ben affleck and anna de armas
are going their separate ways after one
year
of dating e.t confirmed the split on
sunday
with the source saying it was quote a
mutual decision
it's very easy to get distracted by all
kinds of stuff the source told e.t
quote ben and anna have split up and ben
is single they had little arguments and
bickered
like any couple but ultimately the
relationship
just wasn't working in the way they both
wanted it to
anymore this was a mutual decision
they both have a lot of love and respect
for each other
but it was time for them to move on the
source added
quote at the end of the day he chose to
be the dad he continues to want to be
unfortunately they are in different
places in their lives
the couple was first romantically linked
in fall of 2019
around the time they begin filming their
upcoming movie
deep water still trying to take a minute
of a minute
the high profile pandemic romance was
frequently
in the spotlight throughout 2020 affleck
and armist were often spotted in public
together
going on coffee runs and walking their
dogs
there's always a story of the month
during an appearance on the awards
chatter podcast last week
affleck reflected on the intense
spotlight his relationships continued to
receive
and seemingly commented on the media
attention
surrounding his romance with armis still
because they don't go like
i see you out there like in the
paparazzi in the pictures it's like yes
i left my house and took out the trash
it's not like i'm trying to at least
little you're taking a pack walk
as if you leave your house you're only
doing so
in the hopes that you could be so lucky
that you could end up
as the sixth item in the daily mail you
know it's like
it's absurd in december the relationship
had reportedly been going well
a source told et that affleck's ex
jennifer garner
was quote happy for his relationship
and that armist understood their quote
co-parenting
dynamic we do our best we never try our
best
affleck and garner split in 2015
after 10 years of marriage the couple
shares
three children daughters violet and
seraphina
and son samuel the source added
armis was quote close with their kids
and she loved how
affleck was focused on being healthy and
getting in shape
e.t caught up with affleck in march at
the premiere of the way back
where the oscar winner said friends and
family have played an important role
in overcoming his personal struggles i
wonder because the movie is called the
way back
who or what do you credit with the most
help on your own way back
you know i life is to me like doesn't
necessarily fit that kind of easy
narrative
of like uh up peek down and you know
it's steps you know if they're it's
iterative you know um
but i really you know i have a
tremendous like um group of friends and
family and people that
love me and who i love and and that's i
think really really important to
be successful and healthy and happy in
life you can't do it by yourself